joining me today is a guerrilla
journalist the head of Project Veritas
and the author of American Pravda James
O'Keefe welcome to the Rubin report
great to be here long overdue I think is
the way I'm gonna start this one because
you were sort of right in the center of
a lot of the things that I'm constantly
talking about so it's good to have great
to be here thanks for having me okay so
before we get into all your work that I
think most of my audience knows at least
a portion of I don't think anyone knows
that much about you what do we need to
know about James O'Keefe and the man how
did he become this this rogue reporter
and guy that was unearthing all of the
evil things that our tech overlords are
doing to us well I started in college
doing these undercover tapes I actually
started 15 years ago started a newspaper
in college called the Centurion and I
quickly learned that the way to expose
these institutions is to sort of make
them live up to their own principles
like the alinsky tactic I had read rules
for radicals by Saul linski in college
and I I decided to expose hypocrisy by
making them live up to their own rules
and I realized that those rules were
race and sex and sort of abortion these
sort of sacred cow institutions Planned
Parenthood and acorn and I decided to
use hidden cameras I went into the
dining hall at Rutgers ice on st.
Patrick's Day and I said that Lucky
Charms
offends my Irish heritage they took me
seriously and told us they would remove
Lucky Charms cereal is the first video
that I did and from there I actually
went on to work with Lila Rose who you
had on the show recently and doesn't
Planned Parenthood investigations ACORN
with Andrew Breitbart
and I have done some 200 undercover
investigations in the last 10 years I
assume as you do more undercover things
and now you've got other people that are
that are doing a portion of them it gets
harder and harder to do as people know
who you are and know the organization
and things like you'd be surprised I
mean at the moment we rid the Society of
waste fraud and abuse I suppose we will
win the day but people are always going
to be I mean power tends to corrupt and
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
money and and things develop people are
always going to be corrupt so I don't
actually where the camera
these days very often I sort of go out
into the field to be a leader to the
Troops but for the most part it's it's
we've got dozens of these people across
the United States with bringing these
little cameras you put them in you can
put them in a you know Cup for you know
you can put them in a book you can put
them in a watch and as long as you're if
I ask you if there's more than four
cameras in the studio right now because
I got there or there's a few over there
yes yeah but you can you know but as
long as there's one party consenting to
the conversation as long as that you're
talking to someone there's no
expectation of privacy we would argue
and we won in in federal court in
Massachusetts a few months ago we we
change the law so it's we believe that
secretly recording someone is a
fundamental human right it's a
constitutional right because I have no
duty to keep confidential what you tell
me so the hidden camera is an extension
of the reporter notebook and cameras
capture things that words don't I mean
cameras capture intonation inflection
and so we believe that this is a kind of
transparency revolution and there's a
movement of people doing this in a weird
way is it is sort of depressing reality
like when I've watched some of your
videos and and you get engineers at
these companies and we're gonna we're
gonna talk about all of them to admit
things that we all are sort of thinking
or true related to shadow banning or Dee
boosting or everything else there's a
piece of me even when they're there
tipping off the information that I
suspect is true there's a piece of me
that's like this is this is so there's
something sort of depressing about this
that this is what we've been left with
like we have to go after you know
mid-level and sometimes low-level
engineers and sometimes the bigger ones
but because there's no transparency when
it comes to these companies so it feels
almost depressing to me does that make
does that well I think the way that I
would put it like it's unfortunate I
suppose some people call it depressing
some people say it could we confirm
suspicions I would say that what we do
is summon righteous indignation at the
tragedies in society including in these
organizations because they run so
counter to what were spoon-fed the
narratives that were spoon-fed by the
media by the powers that be so
hidden-camera journal investigative
reporting whether it's hidden camera or
print does that it summons what Ida
Tarbell termed as righteous indignation
at the tragedies
and it kind of you know most people I
would say 80% there's a sort of
consensus around what we do people say
well that's wrong or they deny it so
Twitter the Twitter lobbyists in
Congress under oath said we do not
shadow ban when his engineer clearly
said what we do do is shadow ban and we
don't know if we do that anymore that's
what the engineer said clearly meaning
that he had shadow banned people so it's
it's perjury to lie under oath and and
you know these hidden-camera videos
really show people what's going on at
angers people I think the world is more
polarized than it was 10 years ago so
maybe that 80% consensus is going down
yeah are you worried at all though that
will always be videotaping each other
and that there will be nothing that's
private I mean even now if I go out to
dinner like I'm aware that I'm some
level of a public person and sometimes
people recognize me and sometimes I was
at the airport it was very obvious to me
that the guy I was sitting with somebody
but that the guy next to me clearly knew
who I was and he was on his computer and
the whole time I kept paying this guy to
be recording me you know and and just
all like just this endless Big Brother
thing even if the intentions of what
you're doing I I do believe to be good
are you just worried about just that
general state of we're all gonna be
recording each other all then there will
be nothing private I'm not worried at
all I mean there's an element of risk
every time you interact with strangers
and you talk to them as long as there's
one party present to the conversation we
would argue that it's ethical and again
we think that cameras visuals are merely
an extension I mean I could I could
disseminate what you tell me in private
I could write it down and shout it from
the rooftops Upton Sinclair what he
wrote the jungle he saw everything and
then he ran back to his hotel I wrote it
all down
so surely society would would would
rather a situation where I accurately
capture what it is that you told me and
I have to use cameras they indemnify me
because people call me a liar they say
that didn't happen so I have to I have
to record the incidents because they
would they would say that it did not
happen the way that I reported it I also
think that I think that there are lines
that we can't cross we don't go into
people's bedrooms we try to stay away
from the really personal intimate you
know sexual details about about people
but this is a revolution that's aimed at
the power structure at this
establishment the powers that be not
as private citizens and we don't I think
there is a duty there is a
responsibility that investigative
reporters have not to put people on
blast unless it really meets a
compelling public interest so you
mentioned you started this in in college
what was tipping you off to like that
there was something wrong with the media
I mean what made you go I got to go in
there and say I'm Irish and I'm offended
by charms like what really was happening
that you were seeing that led to them
well I was in at Rutgers University in
New Jersey and it was so the political
correctness was run amok like most
schools they'll be there's something bad
happening with the grease trucks please
the grease trucks you know I know the
trucks please tell me that they are ok
it's for those who don't know there's
these trucks at Rutgers and it's like
they're all in a parking lot
and and you get real fat real quick over
your collar there was something you know
what there was something wrong with the
girl
they had duct tape put tape this is in
2005 over these sandwiches and I love to
curse on them you can see there was one
of them called the fat the fat [ __ ] and
the fat Dyke and other words that were
offensive and they had put duct tape
over the names because these words were
considered offensive that's what was the
black what compelled me to try to ban
Lucky Charms so I said this is
ridiculous I also had professors who
were Stalinists I had professors who
were telling me how great communist
communism was and I was not political
but I read the New York Times every day
front to back in college in the dining
hall I was sort of an introverted guy
and I'd read read the paper and I was
just I said this doesn't accurately
capture the world this doesn't this
doesn't tell people what's really going
on so I I felt compelled to do something
about it and it wasn't comfortable it's
not comfortable to confront people with
cameras and you know get into their
faces but I was willed to do it because
I believed in the cause and and the the
kind of a elinsky methodology which is
to make them accountable to their own
principles you know you had these
Marxist professors driving Bentley's and
BMWs and had a little muckraking
newspaper and it was like lifestyles of
the rich and Marxist right right you
know track these people down I just feel
that most people that do this most
insiders inside these companies coming
to us now have what I call it justice
complex they think that there are things
wrong
the world and they feel compelled to do
something about it's hard to explain but
you know I'm sure you know people who
have this complex and these people are
willing to basically jump on a grenade
to wear a camera to film their employer
some cases violating their own
non-disclosure agreement because they
believe the public has a right to know
what they're seeing are you shocked at
the amount of people at these big tech
companies who now are willing to speak
because I mean I know insiders that I
get some information from I mean I'm
talking about Google Facebook Twitter
like that really these things have
become so huge that now their own people
inside them are going whoa what what did
we help create here I'm not you've got a
frac Frankenstein monster I mean I have
you been to Menlo Park and and you go to
San Francisco and I was there because I
did this Facebook story this insider
inside Facebook and I went to try to
locate these engineers and ask them for
comment and there are just these buses
just hundreds of buses filled with
Millennials and and if you go to the
campus people are sort of driving around
these bicycles the best word I can
describe it is they're minions it's just
sort of this little totalitarian little
mini state within a state and it's just
a groupthink
Orwellian place and I and I guess the
word that it was described to me by the
insides that they're all minions they're
very intelligent people but they don't
have a lot of common sense and they're
and I and I went there I was amazed by
this Menlo Park campus buses of young
people being bused in and I think that
it doesn't surprise me that people are
willing to blow the whistle because
there is more to life than then making
you know a quarter million dollars a
year and working for these companies
people want to people want to do
something one of the things that I get
told all the time what can I do and and
there aren't a lot of choices for people
you know you can you can watch the shows
you can buy the books but some people
want to actually participate in this
country and and solutions are
increasingly you know outside the scope
of government the legislative process
does not seem to solve things so there's
there needs to be in a different
counterweight there needs to be a
different solution and I would say that
point zero zero one percent of people
are like put
on me that's a lot of people by the way
yeah right right right we're talking
about a lot of people yeah at the end of
the day so when did you realize that
because you've mostly focused or at
least I think the the work that has
gotten you the most attention has been
related to the tech companies not
necessarily going after politicians or
academics per se although you've done
some of that when did you realize that
focusing on the tech companies was was
really the thing that was going to
strike the chord with most people cuz
that's what it seems well because I
think the media has all the power I
think that I've known this for ever
since I started this endeavor was that
the media has so much more power than
people realize everyone knows the media
is powerful but I think that people fear
the humiliating power of the press I
think the press including the big tech
companies have more power than
government they are more powerful than
all three branches of government the
executive judicial legislative branch so
somehow we need to hold these people
accountable they're not a cat they're
not held accountable by anybody who
elects them and I don't know what the
solutions are people say what should
they be regulated I think they should be
transparent or there will need to be
regulated but they have to at least not
deceive the people so because the media
has all the power I wrote this book
called American Pravda and I believe
that people don't know that they're
being lied to by CNN in the New York
Times and they don't know that they're
being D boosted in shadow band by
Twitter and Facebook and I think these
companies need to tell you that they're
doing it it's not so bad if they take
your account down and restore it but the
thing that's really scary about the D
boosting and the shadow banning is that
you don't know yeah that it is happening
to you and I could just see it you can
kind of feel it there are times when
everything I'm doing is on fire and then
sometimes where it's just like nothing
happens and those usually have a certain
political bent to them and then you end
up really feeling like you're in a
mental institution because if you don't
have evidence of anything I don't want
to be the guy that's running around
screaming everything's a conspiracy and
they're coming after me we're doing this
on YouTube right now even when you do
have evidence we have video tape after
tape of people inside Twitter including
the Twitter direct messaging guy saying
that they have certain keywords and they
consider to be a Russian bot if you
tweet about
guns and the American flag most of these
engineers are not some of them are not
American citizens they don't share
American you know values and this
individual says if you tweet about fly
he's who talks like that who talks about
God you must be a Russian by I have the
videotape and they still couldn't I
still say it's fake
so you know I think that what you know
it's one of those things where people
need to see this stuff and the leave and
I just want these companies to be honest
about what they're doing they just I
just want them to be honest they have to
be honest though I mean we want them to
be honest right so I'm with you I want
them to be honest and and the reason I
apply as much pressure on them on
Twitter and YouTube particularly is
because I want them to be better right
like I I always say this it's like I got
a million subscribers I put out a
television quality show on YouTube for
free and I don't even have an email
address as someone at YouTube I have no
contact right at someone at YouTube like
that's legitimately crazy they're a huge
company that offers a product I'm a user
of the product that helps make them
money through advertising and all that
stuff I can't even get a human there but
I think I don't think I can force them
to be better right well it's the job of
investigative reporting to hold people
accountable to to to test and affirm
what is an outrage to people and I think
that you can't lie under oath you can't
I mean Mark Zuckerberg said in in
Congress last spring some things that
may be contradicted by some of the
documents we've unearthed there are laws
against perjury and the and what people
have to remember is I don't have a
position on whether these companies
should be regulated honestly don't know
what should be done I do know that
people need to know what is happening
inside the companies and I think that
because they're so powerful people have
no idea you when you when you digest
content from CNN in the New York Times
all that stuff gets filled with your
Facebook
in fact when I did the Facebook story I
was shocked by some people in media
telling me well I love the story but I
don't know if I can cover it why not
because we derive most of our revenue
from face yeah the same thing happened
during the 2016 election when I when I
did the Hillary Clinton tapes and the
Bob creamer resign I mean people have to
remember that these companies are
publicly traded companies they get their
broadcast license from the FCC in some
circumstances there's sort of
entanglements there's a sim
Yanik relationship between the corporate
press and the government and for those
reasons again to go back to the campaign
to recruit insiders it's going to
require citizens it's going to require
outsiders to blow the whistle because
since no one and the government is going
to do it indeed many of them are on the
take okay so let's just do each
platforms or one at a time so you just
mentioned Facebook so let's go to face
what what do we need to know about
what's going on with the Facebook
algorithm and the way they're banning
people and suspending people and the
rest of it well I can tell you what our
insider told us saying I can I try to
only speak about the things I I know a
hundred percent and the insider was
working in the content review the
content review tool at Facebook and she
was a contractor for the company and she
leaked us documents inside the company
showing I guess what would be called as
Adi boost of a livestream video and she
said she specifically saw this on
stephen Crowder's page she saw it on a
few other pages she took a screenshot of
a Mike Stern of each page and on the
page it says I action live distribution
this was apparently some type of
algorithm written to from what we could
see to to reduce content that was
suicidal or violent but none of these
individuals were talking or or doing
anything that would rise to that level
now there's two different parts of
Facebook people need to understand
there's a task system where it seems
like Facebook after election hired
hundreds if not thousands of people to
monitor and they do a fairly good job if
your page gets taken down it can be
reinstated you can file a complaint and
and they have a pretty good process but
then there's another part of Facebook
that this insider told us about where
these where this algorithm was occurring
and that was occurring automatically and
they were identifying certain keywords
so she leaks us this troll report it's
called a troll report and after the
election Facebook decided to you know to
get more involved in in things I guess
they didn't like the outcome of the
election and maybe that's what this it
was it was really about I mean
independent people having an impact on
on society they don't like that and
there an end needs more control so they
had this troll report where there are
certain keywords words that were not
racist or problematic really but they
were words that were appropriated by by
right-wing meme culture words like lulz
and norming and even the even the MSM
mainstream media was in this troll
report since typically right-wingers use
MSM more than the left right and these
are just words or phrases or acronyms
that usually you're just meant in meme
funny Sheriff silly ways these are not
not a threat to democracy MSM mainstream
media is not an implication of racism
well they also brought up Lauren Chen
they brought her up it was she was in
there as an example of someone who is
needs to be dealt with visa vie the the
the product intervention at Facebook and
I don't I don't know I'm not aware of
any of any activities or problems with
with her videos I mean she's just
someone who's sharing her mind on
YouTube yeah I'm not sure what order
we're putting these up in but I've got
Lauren Chen coming in here that's a
cosmic coincidence so so that she likes
us these documents we put the story out
instantly what happens is the press the
verge was the name of the outlet comes
out comes to Facebook's defense it
always happens by the way we did this
story on Twitter and instantly BuzzFeed
comes out at Twitter says they don't do
this yeah that's not that's not
journalism yeah I mean Twitter says the
job of investigative reporting is to is
to question what they tell you but it's
always the case when we do these videos
that people come out and they said would
they say they don't do this and it came
to Facebook's defense but the truth is
these documents were real and the two
engineers that we interviewed a guy
named Seiji Yamamoto and Danny Ben David
actually confronted these guys on the
street in San Francisco with a film crew
because no one would give me any answers
but the documents are pretty
self-explanatory and it's it's
definitely it definitely I don't know if
Mark Zuckerberg know is that these
things are happening but if he does he
was lying under oath right so wouldn't
the sensible thing to do if you were
Mark Zuckerberg would be make sure that
you don't reel
you know what's going on at your company
so that when you get put in the position
where you're under oath you can
basically say anything and I think this
would stand true for jacket Twitter and
a bunch of these guys if the buck never
stops with you and I'm sure you saw Jack
from Twitter on with Joe Rogan and Tim
Poole and it was like he just struck me
as oh I don't really know what's going
on with my company but that seems like
it's by design not an accident that's
interesting there's a book by Blake
Harris out in the last couple weeks
about Palmer Luckey and face book and I
encourage you to read it it's
unbelievable that this guy Palmer Luckey
who founded oculus the virtual reality
software was was dealt with by Mark
Zuckerberg directly inside the company
he was told not to be at trial so
actually so I I don't I don't know
whether that's true or not I I did see
Jack Dorsey
he's never addressed anything we've
exposed they don't want to deal with the
actual evidence there's videotapes of
Abhinav a drave who's saying one
strategy is to shadow ban I mean there's
they don't want to actually address the
evidence they want to say well they
don't know what they're talking about
well you know and by the way there is a
difference between I think anytime you
have human beings in a room making
content decisions subjectively you're
gonna have these problems these are hard
problems to solve but it goes back to
the original point of hiring hundreds if
not thousands of people do the content
review I think and at the end of the day
these companies don't like and
independent people influencing the minds
of other people that's what this is
really about and that would actually be
okay if they were transparent about it
sort of because then it would allow
competition to fill that void but this
sort of neither here nor there Ness of
it seems to be the problem so okay so D
boosting seems to be the main problem
with Facebook and that's interesting
that it was hitting Crowder videos and
Lauren Chen and a couple of other people
and this means you're streaming right so
this means when he's streaming that the
number it's just not going to feeds is
that right it's when you're when you do
a live stream video there are special
tags there are special qualities in that
live stream and they they down rank the
video they take away
some of the special qualities that make
it automatically show up on other
people's timelines according to the
insider that we spoke to the other thing
about these videos that our livestream
is that they're converted to text
automatically and and men machine
learning goes through the video and
identifies these keywords so yes the
video would be down ranked it would have
its special qualities taken away and I
think that Crowder settled out of court
in 2016 with Facebook it's what he told
me and I think that he's in the process
of doing some more litigation related
some of the things they're doing to his
videos yeah is there anything else we
need to know on the Facebook front
you've said they've gotten a little bit
better when it comes to they would ban
people and suspend people left and right
all the time I used to have my friend
Faisal Muhtar we've been on the show
many times who's an ex Muslim from from
Iraq and really working to secularize
the Arab world I mean doing incredible
incredible work I mean this is a good
man he would get banned all the time
right and I would have I had a contact
there so I was able to help him get back
on that seems to be having a little bit
less now so I logged in there that the
insiders showed me how it works there's
a I guess if we call task function and
and you know someone gets there there
are there are independent people in the
company low-level people who just make
arbitrary decisions to remove people and
then that's wrong they shouldn't do that
so what there are there are adult
supervision in the room there are there
are people there's like a conversation
thread under each task they convert
these things into what they call tasks
and there are adults that say well
that's no good and there are
relationships with a lot of the
publishers for entities such as your own
and and and there is a relationship
between a sales rep at Facebook and
there seem to be adult supervision but
the problem is with the algorithm side
of things as far as I can see so as part
of it that the algorithm in many cases
they the algorithms were written by
people you know 10 years ago or 15 years
ago probably aren't at the company
anymore nobody really like who really
understands what's going on with these
algorithms do the engineers at these
companies even have a sense of what's
really going on and how can they make
sure that they're not manipulated by the
low-level people and one of the problems
I have is a reporter doing this is
trying to I mean I'm not a tech person
I'm not a I
claim to have any special expertise is
trying to people's eyes glaze over when
you start talking about machine learning
right and and and SSI livestream
distribution so trying to get the people
indignant about something that they have
no idea what this means but yes I think
Danny Ben David wrote the algorithm at
Facebook in 2017 and it was apparently
intended to address violence or suicidal
content and we believe that it was
applied to politics and it was used for
ill that seems to be what happened at
Facebook so you're saying the road to
hell is paved with good intentions right
is that what you're telling me anything
else going on at Facebook we need to
know about and and do you sense that
Zuckerberg may be because of being
hauled in front of Congress will do
anything I can tell you that everyone
inside the company knows what we did and
there's 160 thousand employees they all
know what we exactly what we did and I
think that when we personalize it by
going to the Emmy went to the engineers
doors we went to we went to the train
station where the guy gets on the train
every morning and I interviewed him and
he said I fear for my safety
he's like I'm scared I'm like you're so
good I should be afraid for my safety
you guys are the ones spying on us and
taking our videos down and not to that
but I'm going after this trillion dollar
company but we personalized it and I
think that there's a lot in since I
released this tape a month ago there
have been many people inside the company
that have approached me and I'm trying
to you know it's always the question of
do you want to wear a camera or do you
just want to feed me things anonymously
my medium is video I think that there
has to be video because if we don't tape
these things no one will believe it so
then the person has to basically lose
their job and I'll hire them and that's
how our model tends to work these days
how do you make sure that when someone
reaches out to you that they're not just
trolling you like a triple agent yeah
well basically that they would reach out
to you knowing that you throw up one one
bad thing and there's been little
moments yeah you can get into yes that
that's gonna blow up all of the other
good work that you done so there's high
incentive personality it's a risk it's I
mean listen what we do is a very high
risk for many different reasons which
which we can get into I guess but what
we do is extremely risky
and in undercover work you're gonna get
burned you try to use common sense there
are things that we do you you you you
you you very you go very carefully you
you do your due diligence oftentimes
they send you something there's
something called porcius interference
with with you know violating a
nondisclosure agreement the it's a lot
of complex legal analysis but
essentially they have to tell us
something first and then we can tell
them to film what they have told us so
they're you know we have to be very
careful and and we have been burned by
the way and you probably knows about
some of these things but for the most
part we're 95 to 98% successful not
everything that people bring to us do we
publish not every secret conversation
that I've recorded do we publish I think
it's the choosing to publish something
the video that we've obtained is really
where the ethical calculation comes in
[Music]